foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with economics correspondent at The
Spectator Kate Andrews and guardian
conmiss Zoe Williams
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the guardian preempts another nurses
strike next week as they warn patients
could be put at risk if no resolution is
found the headline Chief nurses worn
over deadlock on NHS pay
she still doesn't get it reads the front
of the Metro as they comment on the
publication of a 4 000 word essay about
Liz truss's time as prime minister
while the I says in its headline a truss
Sparks Tori turmoil over tax cuts
the financial times reports on beijing's
reaction to the USA's decision to shoot
down a Chinese balloon
friends of Nicola bully say vile
theories shared online about her
disappearance are incredibly hurtful to
her family according to the express
the last images of Nicola captured from
a doorbell camera feature on the front
of the mirror which says one hour later
she vanished
and the front of the Daily Star looks at
more icy weather on the way
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by economics
correspondent at The Spectator Kate
Andrews and guardian columnist Zoe
Williams welcome to you both let us
start with the front page of the eye and
their headline trust Sparks Tori turmoil
over tax cut not that easy for me to say
perhaps uh not that easy for Liz trust
to read not very favorable headlines
following her 4 000 word essay Kate
so after this huge Splash that Liz tress
has made in the Sunday telegrapher 4 000
word essay on her view of her
Premiership uh what happened and the
lesson she learned we're now having a
lot of the reaction to that and it's
very telling that some of the
left-leaning papers uh we have those
first we haven't seen the front page of
the Daily Telegraph for example yet or
the mail be interesting to see their
take so far unsurprisingly it's very
critical of what the former prime
minister had to say uh Liz trusts in a
Crux and in a nutshell I think here is
is asking the readers to say to think to
themselves look I I diagnosed the
problem correctly uh please put more
emphasis on that than the proposed
Solutions I put forward which did not go
as well and I think that's a big ask
it's a tough sell and what we're seeing
so far in a lot of the headlines and I
included is that it seems that this is
stirring up a lot of frustration in the
Tory party in her own party uh and it's
uh you know getting headlines of Civil
War and all the rest of it but really
that fundamental debate that started
Journey during the leadership election
last year between Richie sunak and Liz
Tross about when is appropriate to cut
taxes how you cut those taxes and
crucially whether or not you can Finance
those tax cuts through more borrowing is
still playing out in the Tory party it
didn't go anywhere and the fact that Liz
truss is returning so quickly I mean
it's all it's very Vivid in our memories
what happened it was only just a few
months ago the fact that she's returning
so quickly suggests that she feels that
she's been Vindicated very quickly
whether or not her party and the public
agree is a difference is a different
matter yes and uh Zoe she's saying that
she simply wasn't given the the support
she's not apologizing directly but
suggesting that her ideas were correct
but the the infrastructure around her
wasn't there to support her
so there's a sort of logical problem at
the Crux of her argument which is
twofold right firstly experts didn't
warn her and secondly she was stitched
up by the left establishment
um a lot of people are going to be very
surprised to hear the treasury and you
know the international bond markets
called the left-wing establishment but
even if we even if we accept our
proposition that it was a left-wing
establishment that stitched her up it
would make sense for her not to listen
to them if they were giving her advice
because obviously she thought she was
kind of ideologically opposed to them
having said that she also says that she
wasn't given any advice even though many
many people did give her advice and many
many people advised her not to do what
she did
so there's a there's a there's a sort of
veracity problem there's a credibility
problem there's a logic problem there
are all kinds of problems at the core of
her argument which I don't think are
going to really do much to roll back the
image she accrued of being a sort of
flapping incompetent
chaos monkey but actually I think what
people Bond most strongly to is the fact
that you know she had 4 000 words here
not one of them was sorry and many many
people myself included have seen our
mortgages double as a direct result of
that period of turmoil and it never mind
the kind of long-term consequences of
that for the next two five years
depending on where you managed to fix
there was a huge number of weeks in
which people were genuinely in financial
Terror and still and remain so you know
and any time there might have been in to
kind of meet the headwinds of high
inflation and energy costs she wasted
with this mad gamble so I think people
will really what they'll really respond
badly to is the lack of any penitence
which has caused so much hardship but
obviously if you wanted to really pick
the piece apart you could have a field
there a very interesting description I
don't think I've ever heard her
described as a chaos monkey before
that's a person I've heard many
descriptions of of list trust
um Kate why is she doing this now I mean
is this really a strike at Rishi sunak
is she trying to undermine him
I think they're a myriad of things going
on here I think she's looking at the
growth forecasts that have come out so
far under rishi's Premiership of course
so much of that reflects what's already
happened and indeed that includes her
own mini budget and she's thinking to
herself this is my moment of strike I
was talking about growth the UK looks as
if it's going into recession if it's not
already there this is my moment to
comment this is my moment essentially to
start my comeback I think that we make
some important points there though about
in this 4 000 word essay she does say
things like I made mistakes and I'm not
blameless but it is constantly placing
the blame elsewhere she is looking at
different institutions and
establishments and the question that
she's posing again a really tough sell
is to what extent to just a perfect
economic storm gather over the UK during
her 49 days until what extent was it her
fault and it is very difficult for
example to remove all the blame and to
put it on the office for Budget
responsibility and their negative
forecast look in the past they they have
been known to be quite negative about
supply side reforms but there was no
forecast last Autumn because Liz trust
decided that the obr was going to be
sidelined it's very difficult to point
the finger elsewhere especially as a
free marketeer which she's you know
claiming to be when it was International
markets world over which were did not
have a political agenda but we're
looking at her plan to do tens of
billions of pounds of deficit Finance
tax cuts and simply said these numbers
don't add up this is this is not
credible and there is still no
accountability there there's still no
talk about the spending and so you know
I think we have to remember that this is
from her perspective this is her 4 000
words this is how she sees it it's very
clear that she doesn't regret terribly
what she did she even says in the piece
you know I think if we stuck by it it
would have worked we would have got
growth
um and so we have to take it for what it
is which is her account of things but
again because she's decided to intervene
so quickly after the fact a lot of
people will have an account of what
happened we all remember it very well
and there's going to be a lot of
challenge to her timeline a lot of
challenge to those details and big
questions around why she isn't taking
more accountability ultimately she was
in charge
Zoe the Metro saying that she's accused
her successor of presiding over a
Country sliding into stag Nation
um not mentioned by name as I said
before but clearly an attack and really
repositioning herself as perhaps coming
back onto the political stage
well I mean absolutely and this is where
this is the actually interesting bit
quite aside from me calling her names
um why on Earth or newspapers admitting
in the testimony of not just lose trust
but Boris Johnson is launching this
incredible kind of leadership campaign
there isn't a leadership contest so why
is Johnson acting as though there is and
Trust acting as though there is the
reason is they're being admitted into
the discourse by papers like the Sunday
Telegraph and if that's the case that
it's because Richie sunak has lost some
trust in the newspapers he'd expect to
back him so I'm not sure because the
telegraph has been quite wild recently
I'm not sure whether they're reflecting
a kind of broader view in the right-wing
press or whether the canaries in the
coal mine but certainly soon I won't be
looking at this and thinking I can just
write this off as the kind of peebish
ramblings of my predecessor certainly he
has to take this seriously because if it
were just a kind of peevish Outburst
there's no way she would have been given
that space for it interesting okay
tomorrow she's giving her first
interview with spectator television
um is that recorded or will that be live
and do we know any more about that can
you tell us
that's recorded it will be airing at 5
00 pm tomorrow evening on spectator TV
uh the interviewers are our editor
Fraser Nelson and our new political
editor Katie balls and they'll be
following up on a lot of the questions
that we've been asking coming out of
this op-ed and I think pushing that
slightly further as well and yeah I
slightly disagree with Zoe about her
point that you know Publications are
giving this leeway this time to these
politicians these are former Prime
Ministers and when a former prime
minister from either of the major
parties makes a intervention it usually
does end up on the front page of the
newspaper and I think it is frankly very
insightful as to what's happening in the
Tory party right now because uh you know
that debate from the leadership campaign
last summer it has not ended this is a
party that is truly at war with itself
over the fact that it's brought the tax
board into a 72-year high but also the
fact that it can't really name anything
it would cut in terms of spending to
bring that tax burden down because we
have to pay for these things uh and I
think that you know these are sort of
fascinating interventions and almost
regardless of what you think of them it
really speaks with me to politics right
now and I have absolutely no doubt we'll
be getting more insight on spectator TV
tomorrow at 5 pm
I'll allow you that that plug only once
only once though um Zoe let's move to a
different story in the guardian and this
Chief nurse is worn over deadlock on NHS
pay it is looking increasingly as if
this is not going to be sold anytime
soon
it's so fascinating this because it you
know on the eve of the strikes of the
kind of first big strikes before the RCN
even had the whole body of ballots there
was a long period when they only had
kind of majority in Wales and Scotland
and the kind of English Regional unions
weren't quite on side
even then it looked like absolutely
bizarre stubbornness from the government
because they weren't just saying we
can't meet you there we'll meet you here
they were actively refusing to discuss
the matters with Pat Cullen they were
actively refusing to sit round a table
and when they did sit around the table
and ministers were explicitly saying we
can talk about anything except pay now
that is you can't negotiate in a pay
this dispute like that you have to
actually talk about pay so I thought my
view then was that they would see cents
because the public is very much behind
the nurses Union and very much behind
all the NHS stuff actually ambulance
drivers are on extraordinary polling
figures in favor of their strike action
um so there's no way they're gonna just
sit it out and get public opinion to
side with the government or if that's
what they think they're going to do I
think they're going to be disappointed
we read Kate that a government
spokesperson said the health secretary
is ready to resume talks should we read
some optimism into that
I think we've seen in recent weeks that
there has been a shift from the
government and there is more willingness
to compromise but the government feels
strongly I think especially from the
treasury that part of its plan to have
inflation is linked to being very
cautious about pay raises especially in
inflation-based ones as we now see that
headline figure coming down and I think
nurses are the area where there's going
to be most flexibility because as always
says there's a lot of sympathy across
the board and a feeling that especially
after Cove is something has to be done
on pay but we have to look at the whole
spectrum of pay here because we don't
take pensions and those gold-plated
pensions that these public sector
workers have into account either now
that doesn't help with the day-to-day
cost and the cost of living maybe we
need to be more flexible in those
negotiations but when you look at an
average nurse's salary you can
essentially double it when you factor in
the pension something that no private
sector worker can really boast so we
have to have a more holistic talk here
you know the main thing I take away from
the guardian front page is that nobody's
pretending anymore that these strikes
aren't having an effect on on patient
safety the unions are emitting at the
end just recently admitted it you know
this is getting very concerning and as
these walkouts continue you know there's
no pretending that it's not having an
impact
Kate and Zoe for the moment thank you
stay right where you are we're going to
take a break coming up residents in the
Ukrainian city of buckmut are preparing
for a fresh Russian attack we'll discuss
that and more next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me the economics
correspondent at The Spectator Kate
Andrews and guardian columnist Zoe
Williams welcome back to both of you
we're going to kick off with you this
time um Zoe and uh having a look at the
front page of the financial times
Ukraine bracing for a new assault uh
talk us into this
I mean it's absolutely it's what's
really extraordinary about this story is
and I think this is a kind of
um you know this is a castigation of
news generally international news
generally is that as soon as it dies
down or as soon as interest goes away
there's this kind of Bedrock assumption
that things are improving in Ukraine and
they're not improving the longer winter
goes on the worse it gets the Russian
assaults are ceaseless and however bad
the Russian casualty numbers are it
doesn't actually take away from their
military capability which is still
immense so you know and this is the
fight zelenski has constantly is to keep
in front and center in the in the
world's eyes just how much Jeopardy
they're in constantly and is this going
to be the is is this going to be a kind
of new phase of the war are you closer
to the end and the middle or closer to
the middle than the beginning I'm not
sure that we could say that from here
and I'm not sure that you know between
in the Russians trying to talk up their
capabilities and zelenski talking up how
much help he needs it's really difficult
to get a clear picture of whether this
is the kind of Step change in aggression
but it's certainly a really devastating
time for the nation yeah so Ukraine
expecting a large-scale offensive by
Russian forces at any time now
imminently and much of the fighting has
been surrounding back motor in the east
of of Ukraine Kate
yes um just to piggyback a bit on what
Zoe said there and and to think about
the other countries involved in this now
you know over the past few weeks
president zielinski has been making his
pitch making his plea to countries like
Germany to be sending Jets to be sending
other kinds of military equipment and
Germany a few weeks back they they did
change their mind on tanks but he's
constantly having to battle to get more
Weaponry to be able to put up these
defenses to be able to prepare for as
Zoe points out the constant aggression
that's taking place even if it isn't
showing up on our front pages daily
anymore and it is going to be very
interesting I think over the next six
months to see that shift in the Allies
perspective because if it does seem like
this is you know going to be going on
for quite some time especially as
Ukraine at the moment anyway suggests
that uh you know they they are fighting
Russia out of Crimea and all the rest of
it how those opinions start to change in
Germany throughout Europe in the UK and
the US and while there's zelenski and
those other world leaders remain on the
same page yeah so maybe that one
military advisor saying that the assault
could come within that the next 10 days
so this really is uh imminent let's move
to the guardian uh Zoe and this story
about one in ten police officers
slipping through vetting that's
extremely alarming
so it's actually two stories in Oneness
on the one hand one in ten police
officers has an actual conviction or a
known contact with a Criminal underworld
of some sort and is just getting into
them at least anyway and on the other
hand there's a massive um there's a
massive backlog of testimony from female
police officers on how much misogyny
they faced within the force so you know
the the David Carrick case really
lifted the lid on a institutional
culture which actually a lot of people
have been saying for quite a long time
is
institutionally sexist and skating on
the edge of criminality for a really
long time people have been saying that
but it's sort of catastrophic for the
met that everything's coming out at once
so you know on the back of David Carrick
there are going to be numerous
prosecutions of other officers meanwhile
the ambient mood music in the force
itself is shown to be really damaging
every everywhere you look
um there is a real there is a real case
here about whether or not the force can
the Met police can continue and just
reform or where there's something much
more radical has to be undertaken
because it it doesn't look like a few
bad apples anymore
yes and the the HM inspector of
constabulary Matt Parr has said that
there was a real problem with misogyny
within the police that had to be tackled
adding that most if not all serving
female officers had had to endure sexual
assault or inappropriate behavior from
fellow officers I mean this is endemic
isn't it Kate
that's a that's a staggering comment
from him in this piece uh and this is
really a terrifying story to think that
one in ten officers are slipping through
the vetting process and it's a reminder
that those sort of headline figures and
Promises aren't all that they're cracked
up to be I mean you have Boris Johnson
promising 20 000 additional police
officers but it's the Merit of those
police officers it's whether or not
they're skilled inadequate to do the job
it's whether or not they have um the
personality and the professionalism to
do the job and I fear we're discovering
that too many people are are being
approved probably to achieve some kind
of Target who should never be considered
in the first place because they have
criminal records or a background that
would just be completely inappropriate
my officers are struggling from this and
civilians are too okay thank you sorry
you're running out of time there and Zoe
thank you both